bye-bye what do you think about your
daughter-in-law's beautiful
and they actually do things you know
actually do things you know
we're useful good morning everybody
today i'm gonna help my dad build
something for the backyard
so we've had these low pine trees as you
can see rubber like weights down here
they've been blowing over a lot and we
haven't really
tended to the situation down below which
is what kind of like planter or pot are
we gonna put it in all we really wanted
to do was cover this blank wall behind
it because it's our neighbor's wall so
that's something that we just haven't
really gotten to
my parents are in town to train for june
because they're opening for joomla store
in dallas and since they're out here
they're like what can we do around to
you know help my son out well dad since
you're so handy and i'm
totally not a handy person that's a
situation that needs to be tended to
and uh he decided to help us out so
we're gonna go to home depot try to pick
my dad's brain and see if i can
learn a few handy things or two
[Music]
all right just got back from the store
and uh we're looking at
all this lumber we got 35 pieces of this
definitely needed my dad rental suv to
carry all this back home
we've already moved the faux pines over
created a space here
my dad is confident he's gonna get this
done in one day at least by tomorrow
morning he says
quite ambitious i would say 300 finishes
in one day bubba yeah
24 hours though why do i say one day oh
24 hours
so maybe tomorrow night
[Music]
that's good insurance what's up that's
good insurance so this is what the bare
wall looks like and through the window
all we could see is
that and it was so so boring so we
decided to go
with some pines and after that our
backyard is pretty much like
99 done other than tiff's projects
just going to do the stenciling on the
floor irons all this
it's beautiful loving backyard
definitely my favorite project of all
time
in terms of the new house all right i'm
gonna help i'm gonna make myself useful
i have the whole backyard set up and
bubba just taught me how to use this
miter saw that i just got
and i'm so like geeking out over it i'm
so excited i finally have like a
legit heavy duty kind of tool but anyway
he just taught me
how to maneuver the whole thing and we
set up a plane and it's ready to be
cut and i'm ready to become a full-blown
handy woman now so we have the battery
in
we lined up and it's already like
tightened in there
the degrees are correct batteries in
here
now we're ready so what you need to do
is unlock it
slow down
whoa
slowly slowly
okay cool so what you did was too fast
you're going too fast okay so you have
to go slower i'm going to cut 16 of this
thing but this is going to be
your your sample oh so we're just going
to use that to line up to the next one
so i don't have a measurement
oh yeah so now you have battery in there
so yeah
don't touch this yeah just go like this
to see if it lines up low this time
right
slow yes
[Music]
first one the measuring guide the ruler
the
the prototype the the number one i don't
even know
so we just keep on going and then we hit
16.
yeah 16 over casey's missing now
[Music]
all right guys we got half of the
planter box
nice and built already and we're out of
breath and this thing is
so freaking heavy which is exactly what
we needed to prevent these guys
from falling down because we get high
winds here and these these things kept
falling
all the time to the point where we just
gave up and we had them laying flat down
until we kind of built this planter
block but now that we're building it
it's gonna be nice and sturdy
yeah it's coming along very well i'm so
glad that we have you bubba
because there's no way we would have
figured this out on our own
all right so now we are gonna be making
sure that all the wood that we lay down
here is the pretty side because that's
the side that we're gonna be
it's gonna be facing out and that
everyone's gonna see and i was just
telling casey i'm like man i'm so glad i
didn't i haven't stenciled this floor
yet because look
this wood it's like specially treated
wood for like outdoors
so it's kind of wet and stuff and it's
actually staining like this
the concrete here so i'm glad i did not
do the stencil project yet
because then all this would have gotten
messed up what is this there's like rust
here we're building all this out and
it's nice and sturdy because we don't
ever plan
on moving this so if we ever move and we
sell this house they're gonna have this
gigantic lantern box here because
we're not taking it with us i'm loving
using this miter saw i feel
like such a big girl now i get to use it
an actual like heavy duty power tool
which i am loving but because of the
fact that the
wood is treated already and like it's
all wet or i forgot what it's called
what is this kind of wood called
pressurized wood
because of the fact that it's
pressurized wood the sawdust isn't
collecting into the bag that comes with
the saw so we have to keep
stopping every like few cuts and trying
to clear out the
all the sawdust because it's just
accumulating there it's not going
anywhere this is how much
we got so far in here yeah this bag is
like doing nothing
because it's not even sucking up but
it's okay it's least doing the job i'm
having a blast
i am absolutely loving this oh and then
earlier
mama was out here and she was making a
very interesting observation which is
casey loves cooking right so he doesn't
really have an interest in like pools
and like building stuff and all that
stuff but he married a woman that does
that does love this stuff and he loves
this stuff so he gets a daughter-in-law
that he can
make a project with and like build
things with and is actually interested
in
learning how to do all this stuff
because i really like it and then so
carrie's fiance diana
she's like super into the business and
salsara the restaurant
and carrie's kind of like whatever about
it kind of interesting how they both got
with girls
that perfectly compliment the family
because also diana loves dancing salsa
and he loves dancing salsa perfect
pairing you know the chan bros know how
to pick them and we're both mexican too
that's pretty cool
what do you think about your
daughter-in-law's beautiful
and they actually do things you know
actually do things
we're useful hot labor too it's not like
you know doing no thing you know yeah
but they do nothing too yeah yeah i did
my own nails actually
i haven't showed you guys but i got my
own gel kit so i can do it all so what
are you thinking now i'm thinking about
to put the
others out yeah together the face of it
do you need me to cut anymore
no i need you to put this thing together
so i'm going to
use the uh slime okay
just line it up line it up yeah so it's
straight
all right guys we have a pretty complete
box now
well it's not technically technically a
box it's more like a frame because we
didn't put a bottom to it so whenever
it rains it doesn't like trap all the
gunk or
all the bugs and all that so right now
we are thinking of putting
this plank right here to kind of use it
as like a lip so we can cover this up so
it's going to look like this and the
same thing's going to be over here
before we do that we need to first
insert all of these trees and then
put those planks as the lip we're
calling it then we'll be completely done
so in case you didn't know baba used to
be like a civil engineer and also he
just
has done so many handy projects that
this man is like
super experienced when it comes to
constructing things and handling
projects like this so he is a lifesaver
in terms of
building this planter box here because i
was casey and i were planning on doing
it on our own and just trying to google
it and see what we can come up with but
seeing all of the work that bob put into
it i'm like
i don't think we could have came up with
this at all he had a lot of great ideas
which is to
brace the two six feet two by fours
together
to make it extra long because it has to
be like customizable because it's so
huge
and also can you use this this brace
here to like just
kind of bracket it together both pieces
and his original idea was to use one of
these guys
in every single part so then the plants
themselves wouldn't
actually fall like tip over but instead
we decided to use
one big plank to just go across the top
of the planters
and like the actual base so then that
way at least they're
secured that way so i think that's gonna
work and then plus we actually saved
ourselves
a lot of labor instead of doing it
individually i think we're saving some
money too because there's going to be
quite a few things we're going to be
returning
careful so let's put all the trees in
it's coming along oh
let me help you bubba
all right after a long day of working we
have dinner
and it is hot pot because my parents are
chinese and they like
chinese food and we decided to do hot
pot tonight and uh do do people
generally do hot pot for chinese new
year's no it's actually a couple days
away from chinese new year's but i guess
we don't you don't
do hotpot for chinese new year so never
mind
[Music]
um
the wood the wood hey tiff your handy
workout side is gorgeous
look at that oh it's not just me
your handy workout side is gorgeous oh
yeah i did that too i was watching them
true true yeah and i think i i i have to
say your handiwork
your handiwork is outside is gorgeous so
our view from the window has been pitch
black because we haven't had these
lights up in a long time
baba you said you're gonna finish in 24
hours how long how long did that take
outside seven
seven yes he said 24 earlier he did it
in seven
pretty good a lot easier than i thought
you make me proud he had an amazing
assistant
right you make me proud because he had a
great assistant
yeah actually i was just watching her i
actually was doing
a lot of the drilling and stuff that's
true in the cutting part which was like
the mess
oh yeah the design we got the architect
we got the uh
contractor the the g e g c yeah
all right so this is the finale product
right behind me that casey's covering
i'm the finale product yep he's right
there beautiful no
but actually no this is oh yeah let's
get rid of that because we were actually
entertaining the idea of using the extra
wood
for a bench but then ultimately we
decided yeah
we're not going to do a bench we're just
going to leave it as is because it looks
great
bubba you did a fantastic job you do a
fantastic
job mama's admiring it was i a good
helper very good helper
yay help me to cut down some time after
we finish the project in eight hours of
time
yeah we actually did it all in about
eight hours
okay so you know how the main reason
where we built this is to prevent these
trees from toppling over because of the
high winds
baba had a really great idea and that
was inside of this
box he actually added this beam
across the entire thing so it's actually
right on top of the
planter base so there's no way this
thing can like tip over in any direction
because it's fully being
secured down with these beams and so
in the morning he came out here and he
secured the beans in there and
if we ever for whatever reason we ever
need to remove this we first have to
remove the lip that we added
so we added like the whole top better
remove that and then we gotta remove
this block here and then we can lift
these up because these aren't
actually secured in any way other than
with this blocks that's how
it's all nice and secure so no matter
how hard
we wanna move it it's not going anywhere
and
last night i spent some time trying to
hide the string lights there i hid the
string lights i fluffed up
all of the trees put them in every
single slot
and now it's complete and all you have
to do is enjoy it oh i did bring in the
lumber i know i'm kidding
i'm using really little these muscles
right here ooh they look good
he's like it's really tight i need a oh
my god i give you a compliment and then
you take it back
you know thank you we all it's a group
project here we all work together to
complete this
and look how cool so we ended up like
offsetting the wood so it kind of like
has a little zigzag design
there we go and then the fact that baba
picked this wood specifically
and ended up making it just really easy
to not have to stain it or
yeah it's already nice and completed
because i
i don't really plan on doing anything to
this wood so now we have this extra
material
well not including this but this we're
going to return
and there's other stuff around the house
that that's what
you got to return oh now
that sorry i interrupted you but i got
really excited because i haven't shown
you guys
the other stuff i've been doing around
the house i added
this to the front door so i
got some pinstriping tape because this
is just tape so i actually didn't paint
it and i just
pin striped around the entire door so
now it has like a kind of
fancy-ish look this is what it looks
like i am obsessed it looks so
good and i was actually trying to record
the process of me doing this because
it's super easy it was super fast but i
couldn't find my
tripod thing from my cell phone so i was
just like you know what i'm just going
to do it and just show you guys after
oh and then baba she ended up helping us
deck out the garage
so hey built out these cabinets and then
bubba helped us put
this shelf up here for extra storage and
the bike rack and luckily we're still
able to
fully open this and it doesn't hit so
that was a success
and then up there we're gonna store all
the helmets and stuff and then i added
this light here because there's no
light switch on this side of the garage
so every time casey was coming in it was
always really really dark
so i added this motion sensor light that
solved that problem in terms of the rest
of the garage everything in this corner
minus the ladder
is meant to go away we're in the process
of selling it
and donating it but this is the last bit
of it oh minus the boxes too because
those cardboard boxes
are gonna go up there but everything
else
we're gonna be selling and donating and
getting rid of and so
all of this space here it's gonna be
completely cleared out and
we're gonna have enough space to put in
a whole nother car
in here finally i could pop the car in
the corner
finally casey's car can fit in the
garage you know
i was thinking i was like man my dad
built helped build this uh
planter thing in the backyard and like
growing up my dad's always
built stuff like for me like for like
for the family and like
to be able to like have our own house
and still have like a little touch
like or my my grown-up house i'm like
that's cool built in the tree house
before i built it you
had a tree house going a fort
cool i didn't know that he designed it
and built it himself
wow how come you didn't learn anything
from your dad
i mean i've tried even this time i've
got sat there a couple times
like yeah screws over there yeah and i
get it but then it's like
i don't know it doesn't interest me yeah
like i helped with the rack here too
yesterday the bike rack yeah and i was
like i get like the problems like he
needed to
you know line up with the stud and all
these things when i get it it just
doesn't it doesn't get me going
to be like what's the next project you
know but it is for you though yeah yeah
so it works out it works out and then
the other thing we did
in the office well currently it's set up
as a guest room
for mama and baba so we have this
bed here which the engineering behind
this bed i am very proud of
and i'll show you that in a second but
look look at the closet doors so
i ended up pin striping the doors first
this is my first project and same thing
i just use this
tape and it was so easy to apply
my favorite thing ever oh and i also
spray painted these gold
so it match and i didn't like how white
it was up here so i ended up adding the
layers but i'm not a fan of how you can
actually see
the layers but it's fine it works out
i'm so proud of the closet doors
and same thing i was trying to like
record it and time lapse it and i got
too lazy and i was just so excited i
just wanted to do the doors already so i
don't have footage of me doing this but
it was
super easy it was really quick for me to
do it i'm very proud of it
and now i'm so obsessed with it i kind
of want to pinstripe all of the doors in
the whole house but i'm not going to but
i really want to but i'm not going to
that's just going to be overkill but
yeah the engineering behind this
bed though so you guys know how there
was the blue futon before and the futon
is here
so here's a futon but it is too small
for two people
so we have this memory foam mattress
that we purchased for the intention of
taking it
camping but it's just way too big to
actually keep for camping because it's a
queen-size mattress it's foldable
memory foam super comfortable but it
just takes a block space so i was
planning on
selling it and getting rid of it but it
actually came handy for this purpose
but like i said it's bigger than the
futon right so what i ended up doing
is i added these stools to support the
mattress up
and it actually works really well mama
and baba say that it's super comfortable
they don't even notice that it's not
like all one solid piece
so i think i'm gonna end up keeping this
mattress it actually serves as a
really good purpose and now we have a
queen
size guest bed that we can easily remove
when we don't have guests but if we ever
have more kids who knows what we're
gonna do we're not gonna have
a guest room because this will be a
nursery we ended up taking out casey's
chair and moving my
chair over here just so they can have
more room in case these chairs in here
right there and then there's the teenage
boy gaming forever hi baby
well daddy and i are going to go to ikea
if you want to come or you want to say
so isaac wants me to finish this door
he does like the design he wants it i
will complete it
so this door will look like that door
and it'll match that thing i'm really
proud of my house
i really like it i know it's not
everyone's taste and that's perfectly
fine
but i freaking love my house and it's so
fun like all the different colors
and all the different designs i love all
the wallpaper
and all the patterns and just like
trying to really make
every single inch of this house as fun
and vibrant
as i possibly can make it and i think
i've done a pretty banjo job and casey
loves it so that's all that matters
that's the house the current condition
of the house that's the planter box over
there
very proud let me know what you guys
think in the comments i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
me